what would I do on Tik Tok you would do
whatever you want Sean aie that would
probably get at least 100,000 views give
him a wedgie that's at least a million a
million Atomic attention is the number
one asset what would you go as if you
had a costume at ComiCon that if that
30% turned into 70% what would you dress
up there I'd go Batman for sure like I
said the other one that I would play out
is The Flash is very big for me like
when I think about Comics like just you
know I was never really fast you know
you understand that right you know you
you know and so uh and so I think the
flash uh the flash would probably uh be
in consideration as well no doubt all
right you're very big in the digital
world so like in-person events like that
they're still very important to you yeah
I think you know even hearing uh as I
was about to come on talking about it's
nice to be back in studio I think I I
think you know Co did a lot of things
changed the world in a lot of ways but I
think for a lot of people I think it you
know makes people appreciate being
together as well I think it's great that
we now know how to use zoom and hangouts
and you know I'm sure for both of you
it's saved some travel I used to travel
literally every week for my businesses
pre-co now not having to because you can
have the meetings virtually but going to
things ComicCon coming to the stadium it
was funny I was my trainer is a big
Vikings fan and we were talking like I
hadn't brought this up in a while we
talked about the season when they played
with our fans and like you know like you
know what I mean and just like it's
crazy and so I think I I love people
like even all this incredible crew that
you have behind you if if it was less if
it was just us recording with a camera
my energy would be lower I like people I
like that part and yeah so even though
I'm all about digital really I look at
digital as a gateway to in person sure
you know like a lot of people talk about
like these kids don't have relationships
anymore they're all so introvert I'm
like no they're not they make the
relationships on Twitch on you know Xbox
on social and then they meet those
people in real life they have more
friends than we did we had the friends
that we grew up with in the neighborhood
right and so you know I don't demonize
digital and I definitely don't demonize
in person I think the world is both and
I like them both I like it I like it all
right now we got we got to do this okay
you're a Jets fan big time Big part of
your life El I have not missed a snap I
need you to hear this what year were you
born 81 this is amazing the 1982 season
is my first Jets season they went to the
AFC Championship game by the way they
tricked me um but I've literally not
missed a snap of a New York Jets
football game on TV or physically since
no DVR no TBO no unfortunate thing thank
God in my life of a funeral or you know
or a a good thing like a wedding nothing
zero missed none of them so I'm not a
Jets fan like you know there's levels to
it just like you guys were alltime
players there's levels to being a player
there's levels to being a fan I've not
missed a snap since basically your whole
life that's impressive I think Mike
Greenberg would be impressed by that
might be impressed by that so you're
above both of them in as far as
accountability yeah I mean I like it it
is disproportionately my biggest passion
I'm a overall big sports fan there's
other things I like I grew up in the
wine business I like that world but Jets
football four sure well it's not easy
being green no not in this town and by
the way the way I became a Jets fan was
I moved to you know Edison New Jersey
when I was seven I went outside bunch of
kids were throwing a Nerf football and I
again like I said earlier I just moved
to the country I'm just learning the
ways and they're like what's your
favorite team I'm like I have no idea
and if Eric Godfrey if you're watching
Eric I'm still upset about this all he
had to do was say Giants and I would
have four Super Bowls but he said Jets
and I have no
appearances and so uh yes it's it it is
definitely a challenging Journey but you
know what's interesting it worked out
for me I grew up a big Yankees and
Rangers Fan but when the Rangers won the
cup in '94 and the Yankees won in 96 it
took everything out of it I'm now
disproportionately Jets Knicks with
those two teams because they've already
won like celebrated that like hey done
that check the box I want I want to I
want it's funny I know it's not the
normal way for a lot of fans a lot of my
friends are like that's so stupid what
is that that's crazy I just can't help
the way I feel something about this as a
fan is about the climb right and then
when you reach it it becomes different
for me and so it's probably like your
business is like you kind of grow them
you want to you want to get them early
grow them grow them grow them like all
right move we hey we accomplished it get
out let's start a no one it's very
common for entrepreneurs to do that my
two core businesses the wine business in
Jersey Wine Library and this Viner media
business I'm building they're like
forever family businesses but to your
point it is very common for
entrepreneurs to only like the beginning
yeah that when it hits scale and you
have to worry yeah when you have to
manage 100 people like it changes and so
yeah that's how my sports fandom has
worked I want the climb I like the pain
I like the Heartbreak at some level so
the Jets have been good to me in some
ways you like the pain take the pain
Soldier let's talk about the good with
jets a favorite Jets
player well so uh just to context this
seven years ago my brother who was my
partner in the marketing company uh
decided that he wanted to be an NFL
agent so we rep SAU and DJ Reid both
Corners so as you can imagine they're
going to play out a certain way but I'm
a funny fan like like I'm deep like Chaz
Sarat who's like a special teams
linebacker who I loved at North Carolina
is like a player I literally genuinely
like and I think number 82 Gibson I
think Gibson um is the x- factor this
week my my deep gut feel is that it's
going to be his you know he's someone to
look out for this week cuz I think it's
going to be a tough game to your point I
think both def the Giants defense is
making me nervous the last two weeks
they look really strong and we're not an
offensive Juggernaut um but you know it
tends to be like you know players Tony
Adams the safety I'm obsessed with he
had a obviously a monster most Jet fans
that are casual got to know who he was
last week because of the pick um on Herz
and so there's a lot of guys on the team
and plus I'm so fortunate at this point
I'm such a big fan we're in the business
um I'm I've recruited a lot of these
kids
at this point I know a lot of the guys
and so it gets hard when you know about
seven or eight years ago it started to
cross over into like I wasn't just
watching it on TV I started to get to
know them personally sure even like like
for example last year Brax and baros was
one of my favorite players and bra is
like the best dude I love bra but I hate
bra now cuz he's a dolphin I'm watching
him last night like I want nothing every
time he like took a punt or a kickoff
last time like do not run this back cuz
I'm mad now and so you know it gets
complex I'm sure for you guys as well
like you guys played the game you know
the guys in the locker room like you
know I'm I'm not sure for either one of
you two if when and if it ever crosses
over until you can be a normal fan
there's no normal Fan Experience for you
guys especially with you doing this for
a living but you know the guys and you
have players that you definitely
appreciate the way they play because you
understand it deeper and I think you
know it all goes into all that right
Justin Hardy who won't play this week
cuz he's hurt which is a big blow to
Jets like I love him because I actually
am at the point in my fandom where I
like really appreciate the Gunner sure
and I understand what it means and I
understand like how that could be a
factor yeah I'm impressed the fact that
you know what a gunner is you you got
Chaz I could learn I don't know what I
have no idea what you're talking about
Gunner what you talking what is that the
P I'm aware you I love it sounds almost
like you're like kind of want to get
into ownership with the Jets is that
you've done your homework it's the Woody
Johnson about this I haven't because I
think it's super inappropriate that if
you can't afford it then you're just a
poser and like a clown and I have no
interest in embarrassing myself or
wasting his time but yeah I mean you
know and I'm proud of this like in my
sixth grade I don't know why my sixth
grade asked everyone to like predict
what they were going to do when they
grew up but like literally in the little
fake yearbook cuz it wasn't even like a
real yearbook but in our end of the year
picture in sixth grade in uh John Adams
Middle School in Edison New Jersey like
everyone's like and ask astronaut or an
architect was big in the 80s I don't
know if anybody everyone was going to be
an architect than mine was owner of the
New York Jets so somewhere around so in
first second third grade I was like you
guys I dominated in football I heard I
had great you heard about it right it
was huge still talking yeah your dad was
like sending me messages like I was I
was coming um I have very very good hand
eye coordination and so first second and
third grade were remarkable for me
around fourth grade that's when speed
strength
athleticism size things started to like
come into play that did not go in my
favor so somewhere around fifth or sixth
grade I'm like I'm probably not going to
play for the Jets and so but at that
point I was already doing the baseball
cards thing I was doing lemonade I was
very entrepreneurial before that was a
word and so I decided that I wanted to
own the Jets and you know as I sit here
today like even walking in here and like
like I continue to have that dream I'm
aware that it's going to require a lot
of things to go incredibly well over the
next three decades but I'm I'm here for
it if you were if you were an owner you
know let's say couple decades owner or
hey next year you become owner what are
some things you'd change within the NFL
uh within the NFL you know I think if I
was in committees and like and we're
talking about
things I think the subjectiveness of
roughing the passer is is a real pain in
the ass you review that reviewable you
think I would like that I think that
would make us fans and like I I think
that is probably the most needed
reviewable play I think they should ask
the quarterback you know on some like
hey was that passer like no no no he
like barely brushed my dramatic yeah
like there's some that are like like
yeah asking for the penalty they're like
he hit my face but he touched my face
like it was like it was it was a gentle
brush I'm going to say if they call it
you could like quarter some quarterbacks
it's like the honor System basketball
yeah you should be like it off like no
no
no was a
foul no but but I think look I think the
fact that we if we were if we're making
pass interference a reviewable play I I
think roughing the passer is a hard
right now and and you went through this
I'm sure in your career and I think in
your era it was obviously different than
it is now but I'm sure you even felt
consciously or subconsciously that at
some point you started earning the
respect of the league and the refs and
just the vibe right and that it would
then be more likely that you would get a
call than not I mean you know you know
and maybe you see it different I'm
that's actually in question form I'm
curious if you think that I can tell you
as a Jets fan we're tired of the NFL
finding a player for hitting Zach and
not getting a flag we are now by far the
longest tenure team in the league
without a roughing the passer and I
think a lot of it has to do with Zach
not earning his you know I look at what
Jaylen got you know what what Watkins
got called yesterday on jayen Zach's not
getting that call and that might be a
delusional Die Hard fan saying that but
the data supports it and so I think a
reviewable play for that would be big
you know I think that stands out
tremendously to me as one of the things
that is a little bit of like an anxiety
for fan bases um and the league and I
think it would make it a good product I
think the other thing I would do I
really like what's going on with this
flag football thing yeah I don't want
our football to become flag football
tend that way with listen you know and I
get that and look look safety I get it
I'm I'm for it like I missed the
kickoffs I missed that a lot the returns
used to be such a factor back Y Line
yeah I by the way the I mean for all the
Die Hard Jet fans people ker kicks it
from the 15 but everybody else can start
at the 30 you know like just get the
ball like they you know 50 I think
something the kickoff had them start up
there 50 something I I can tell you for
for the for the the probably small group
of Die Hard Jet fans that are watching
this right now the Rex Ryan years if we
don't have Brad Smith returning I mean
the Jets that Sanchez offense was Bleak
yeah our special teams I mean we beat
the Steelers in a game that mattered
because of a brad spit kickoff the the
Colts like these were these were they
were essential for the Jets back then
and and I missed that part of the NFL so
that's that's another rule that I am
curious to look at but I you know the
league has done a really good job in a
lot of ways and um I think a lot of the
rule changes the crackback blocks that
are now being thrown a lot I think
that's good like guys you know what it
is you guys know this these guys are
getting so big and fast like when people
get into real conversations with me
about this I'm like guys do you
understand the average guy what he his
speed and strength compared to 30 40
years ago when we were growing up like
these guys are so big and fast like
we've had these are appropriate
adjustments yeah we're trying to make
the game SA no doubt um I want to go
back to something real quick cuz rumor
has it that your jets fandom started
because your mom made you a
sweater it's probably the same color as
the one you're wearing right now it is
actually take us back to that sweater
what thank you for bringing that up I
don't I'm going to try not to cry on the
on the El Manning show um so you want to
be it was so the I can all the
time the story is pretty quickly after
the story I told you about Eric Godfrey
and Robbie turnick making me a jet vanan
instead of a giant fan so now they're
like you're a Jet fan this is right
before school starts late August the
season starts this is a Jets team that
goes to the AFC Championship game it was
a strike season which is interesting so
it was kind of I didn't get to see our
real players for a little while
nonetheless everybody H everybody in my
town has like those old raggedy 1980s
jerseys not the stuff we all wear now
like the half t-shirt like your your dad
Saint Jersey like that style like the
T-shirt jersey so everybody had a 24 or
an 85 for jet bands that was Freeman
mcneel and Wesley Walker and I wanted
one cuz we would play every day every
day we'd go to school we'd come home and
as soon as we got off the bus the green
and white Nerf ball backyard pickup
football every day every day and so I
wanted one but we were like pretty poor
in that we were just starting to get out
of like poverty like we moved to America
I lived in a studio apartment in Queens
with eight family members dead dead
poverty like a 100 bucks to our name and
now we're heading into like a little bit
of like lower middle class my parents
were not going to buy a $25 Jets t-shirt
so my mom at night knitted me a Jets
sweater that I would wear with the
number five on it because that was my
favorite number that was also Pat ley's
number he was our kicker um but it is my
prize possession and it's always been my
dream to buy this team and in a stadium
like this whether it's this one or
cuz I anticipate to buy in 20 or 30
years if I have to build a new one um to
put the sweater in the front when people
walk in and I wanted to say you know you
can literally do anything you know from
not being able to buy a Jersey to owning
the whole darn team I have that ambition
and it's and it's um my mom is my hero
my mom is my Foundation my dad's
unbelievable but like I was an ' 80s kid
my mom was home my dad worked all the
time and the level of self-esteem she
built without delusion and she's my hero
and um that Jersey is the most important
physical thing I have all right
obviously Jets Giants this weekend I'm
feeling a a friendly wager or
non-friendly either non friendly non
friendly you remember on the giant side
I by the way I'm confused when giant
fans don't like the Jets they you've won
four Super Bowls we won nothing you're
clearly the more popular team in the
area like what's the problem Jet B it
Mak sense beef I don't think there's a
lot of beef I think I mean you only play
every four years it's a little bit of
who runs Theo you got to like people ask
you about it so you got to you got to
this game is though this one timed out
to be a monster game for both teams yeah
like the team that loses this week is
not going to feel great about their
season so what about something where
maybe if Giants win you wear a Giants
Jersey not happen iar I've never worn a
Kon Tibido cuz he's number five I would
wear Oregon tibo cuz it's a five but
like not not a Old Miss Old Miss I would
wear okay what your college Mount Ida
College there is no Jersey so there's no
Jersey sounds like a
good you'd have to drink a 40 and play
CEO you know like if you want to do my
college Spades like if you want to do my
college social media hit you got to say
great win by the Giants this weekend I
can't do that I can't do that like what
about what about wine I know you like
wine I could put up a great case of wine
from Wine Library that I could do all
right I and for maybe Panini cards I
like cards like pan all
right sounds a little
bitard and some wine there we go all
right that's a it's a bet get in here
all right Gary we know you're a big
social media influencer um Eli is is
kind of new to the social media aspect
wait till he was retired to open up the
social media accounts which I think was
wise he didn't want to blow up in he
could he could hear the feelings in the
stadium he didn't need to see it on the
internet I didn't need to hear the booze
in coming out your phone but I just give
Eli some tips you know since he's new to
this what can he do to grow his
influence following you know I think the
thing that a lot of us loved to learn
about Eli especially postc career but
you can even see it when he was playing
is the sense of humor thing is there and
so for me Tik Tok is something that is a
real worthwhile Venture for you I think
dance moves to dance that that's what
everybody thought like six seven years
ago Tik Tok is now the predominant
social network and it is very conducive
to humor what would I do on Tik Tok you
would do whatever you want right and so
like literally even like a Sean a noie
you that would probably get at least
100,000 views give him a wedgie that's
at least a million million
Atomic over the head mil that's 10
million but but I but I really think Tik
tok's one place to look I think the
other place I you know one thing I've
also observed from afar we haven't
really chopped it up um but your
business Ambitions are real and so
LinkedIn has actually become a monster
social network and I think people still
think of it as like a recruiting tool
but using LinkedIn as a social network
to talk about your business observations
the things you're thinking about the
kind of businesses you're interested in
business advice that you've learned
things you've learned about
entrepreneurship that's similar to the
athletic realm I think LinkedIn would be
another place to really think about it I
think those two stand out if as as a
third I I do think and I continue to
believe this
we talked about it earlier about the
Gunner or like things that you know when
you guys watch football you see
different things than the Casual fan I
Still Believe on Twitter breaking down
something yeah that people don't see and
you guys do this anyway but on social
breaking down something that people
don't understand um I think is very very
valuable because what we see and you
guys know this I've always been
fascinated by the film room the next day
because I've seen players through the
years I understand football enough to
know that there's certain people in the
secondary who don't want to take the
blame for a mistake and will literally
react to get the crowd to think it
wasn't their fault correct and I'm like
but that guy has to go in and they're
like pointing and they're like no no
that was your assignment right the guy
defensive guy comes over and he goes
that was my fault I messed up that
coverage I can't believe I blew that
it's not on you and everybody thinks
that he's yelling at the other guy and
so I think I think like jumping in
Twitter social commentating of like what
happened there was two guys ran the
wrong route that's it happened last
night reason slay got that pick was two
guys ended up in the same place clearly
something went wrong yeah those kind of
observations in real time on social are
wildly valuable I so what basically what
I'm gathering is on Tik Tok Eli should
break down the butt fumble yes I think
you should break down the butt fumble
actually you know what's so funny Sean
the butt Bumble doesn't hurt me I'm just
trying to get out of here without
talking about Victor Cruz's touchdown
against the Jets to this day and Eric
Smith if you're watching I loved you
number 33 for the Jets great player nice
hit hard almost ended Anquan bolan's
career here but that play like literally
I will go into this Sunday thinking
about that praying to God you blaming
Eric Smith or you BL I'm blaming Eric
Smith I know I know I know I
know yeah great throw Kari blown up
Victor yes I understand but I I still
have a lot of feelings I understand that
started the Sala yeah that was like
crazy right there what really crazy you
know what's crazy about Victor's career
I was here for that pre-season game I
was like who this
guy like the
same y but it you know and I remember
and we were just coming off of corbette
coming out of left field you know four
or five years seven years
earlier uhhuh and I was like man I hope
this Cruz character isn't a real player
he ended up being a very real player no
doubt I'm just curious were you here
when Eli bled during the Jets Giants
preseason game I sure did I I remember
that was scary I I was I I've been here
for every I was here for October
943 I was here for the Brandon Marshall
in the corner like that was the big one
for us we but we didn't make the
playoffs in 15 but the game we won here
it was uh I mean that's why I'm excited
for this Sunday it's going to be the
second time I'm in this Stadium as a as
a road visitor and so we'll do it again
all right G we got our Panini cards here
pack breaking let's pack break breaks
what are we call what are we calling
this when box it's a box but these are
packs pack but hold on Eli what about
this let's let's talk about your
signature that's pretty good don't you
think I'm pretty impressed this feels
like this was the first one in a sitting
no cuz you know you know you're a
quarterback so your hand probably
doesn't get yeah you never it's hard to
screw up like Eli you can't shorten that
that much actually it's like a big pet
PE of mine autographs like we have some
like you get like a ball of a bunch of
people sign it you're looking through it
you're like I don't know I can't tell
you one autograph of this whole ball
it's like it's like a symbol of I'm like
so I take I I take a lot of time I that
was a very nice guy thing to say observ
because like once you get to like the
100 autograph sometimes 100% I like that
it says retro that just kind of lets you
know
me got you all right what are we
thinking about here who we got here
Chase Brown Chase Brown keep going is he
a gunner Spears gun Spears he got card a
little patch see that little o I got a
big one here three out of five okay this
is exting because Dez Ritter is by
Vayner Sports we signed him out of
Cincinnati he had a really challenging
play this weekend fumbled at the goal
line I don't know if you saw it but he
played pretty well so that's three out
of three out of five and auto his
autograph oh you guys wait a minute did
you guys load this pack no who you guys
wait a minute you guys loaded
this that I got all excited about the de
I thought it was actually natural is
that a Rookie of the Year card I look
very good in this rookie what year is
that I'm very old in on the it's just a
no stats what's the hand what do you
think that's what do you think that's
worth right there so I this is probably
worth at least six to7 million you know
that's what I'm taking you can buy the
Jets that five oh M you okay so you guys
loaded this pack I appreciate you're
very sweet you just scanned over momes
well I'm yeah man I'm just very I want I
want to see what you naturally got all
right Jake the rookie and the Saints you
know okay you got the card o ooh this is
a nice little card with the look at this
wa like went back like throw all a so
you can go he can get a really cool card
see this is called nightlights and this
is I mean a pretty that P Panini did a
nice job they do nice work will Le right
you never
know you it for a while see what happens
that's what a quarterback's arm should
look like right there you see that see
that bicep this was like a big part of
his draft you remember sleeves were just
long they covered him up this kid's
playing well by the way who's that
little spoon yeah spoon spon's playing
well I think he actually had an intercep
against the Giants here did you bring
that up on purpose I did not but I hope
we get one this all what do we got here
all right here we go Camu he's a nice
little
player we we got a little here rash he
had a nice K by the way there's the auto
look at this Auto where RR RR what is
that he's more strategic than you he's
trying to get his work done quickly
signed it in silver you can't see that's
Richie Rich right Rich he a nice little
player all right take your time sign the
autograph here we go Analyze That Jaren
Hill Hulks
backup quarterback I want if we see
another one autograph I'm to cover the
name I want to see if you can read it
Deuce dece V there we go for the Cowboys
yeah that was what happened in that
cowboy game what happen what the first
game of the year what happened to talk
about that no okay we're ready we don't
talk about Bruno and Drake nice little
player five again you go he one of your
clients there was a back we're going to
look at the stats here yes all right so
kind of look so you have your like maybe
your birth birth November 14th 75 1975
correct born Soviet Union you don't see
that very often that's definitely not in
the NFL maybe a couple maybe a couple
offensive linemen at some point
obviously everybody lies about their
heights it might say 5'9 on there but
it's really 5'8 don't tell anyone please
favorite team Jets yes favorite drink
wine yes skills what's your skills
social media talking I think my skills
my true greatest skill is taking as
taking on stress and converting it to
not be stressed for the people
underneath me what about your big do you
think that's a big that's a big thing in
in your guys game right I really think
that that is the most obvious variable
to me in leadership someone who doesn't
magnify the stress on everyone but is
able to be the diffuser underneath their
team sounds like a quarterback a lot of
quarterbacks yeah when you lose hey you
take the blame I got the shoulders put
it on me you win then you disperse all
the credit to receivers all onine
offensive line you let you know you kind
of take it on you El let me ask question
lineman cuz we're tasing we're taking
all the defense on the stress on and
trying to make their job easier yeah
you're doing all the hard work and they
get all the glory exactly Eli real quick
I've actually always wanted to ask you
this your overall like demeanor yeah
very cerebr like like did you develop
that or is that your was that your
natural personality or did you develop
that I think that's my natural
personality always pretty pretty quiet
kind of watching The Room analyzing um
you know don't don't say anything unless
something truly needs to be said you
know just kind of let let you know show
up work hard do all those things things
really let your actions speak more than
your words but you think that Serv you
in yor yeah I think so just but when
something needed to be said you say it
and people listen to it they're like hey
he's saying something here he said much
he said much like we got that means hey
we got it we got that how it was was
that how the locker room received it
yeah yeah we had enough guys on defense
that were talking they were talking
non-stop it's like all right already but
yeah I think it it means a lot more when
it's so you know it's coming from your
peers and when it's you know hey look
not somebody that raises their voice
like he never really yelled at guys so
but if he got if he got like fired up
like you knew like this is important I
went a big pregame I never I never felt
that a pregame speech has ever won a
game before you know like that's like
the defense hey get everybody riled up
like I'm not going to get guys red up
I'm trying to stay calm like I can't
like get you fired up when I'm trying to
just stay like stay calm so you know
leave that spray hand let him stomp it
out I uh I you know I've been running
businesses my whole life and the and was
the oldest brother in my family and just
in general
really Pride I'm very loud and I'm over
the top and I'm an extrovert yeah yeah
it says that on your yeah I see it but
but I was very very proud that like when
bad stuff's happening I always wanted to
be the person that stopped it and and re
formulated it for everyone below me and
I think that Services me well as a CEO
as a parent and I think that's that's a
real thing that people can work oning no
doubt definitely working working you've
had great success excited for the game
this weekend I'm excited to guys so much
for coming such a pleasure congrats on
everything course I know you're a big
garage sale guy like here's our garage
sale you walk up like what's the first
thing that pops your eye the Leonard the
Leonard gloves I'm a big boxing guy you
know cuz you know I love UFC now but I
grew up in that 80s 7s 90s boxing and I
don't think people understand how much
of a beast sugaray was cuz he was such a
pretty boy I don't think people and they
think he was smooth but he was nasty and
some of his wins in his career
especially the Hern win I think are
special so that caught my
eye I saw that the hav Sandy kofax and
Pistol Pete who's like rookies both
rookie cards I know these are gorgeous
gorgeous Pete look at that this people
kofax was great but the honestly besides
the gloves the Boston Garden original
bench like yeah yeah this is crazy this
is absolutely crazy you wore that I
didn't wear this no you're rocking some
js so the homemade sweater like your
homemade s that's what it looks like
I've never worn a pair of Jordans in my
life cuz I'm such a Nicks fan and I hate
Michael Jordan so much that I've never
ever worn a pair of Jordans in my life
I'm wearing Air Force Ones or dunks but
no Jordans I don't think any real Knicks
fan over the age of 40 should ever wear
a pair of Jordans if you're if you're 25
you weren't affected by it you don't
you're not mad at it it's cool like good
series those were those were heated
heated the heated
sauce and quinnon look at those what
what Eli no no no this is this is this
is the key to
Su did you bring your own stuff to the
oh there's a giant in there saquan and
this is quinnon tackle saquin yes that's
what I want for Sunday about this this
little van what is that Eli um is that
what you take in the summer you guys go
road trip family trip this is shagg I
love it the weedies boxes were huge in
the ' 80s and 90s
yeah of champ there's food in there Sean
you can still eat the Wheaties they're
probably good yeah they I don't think
there's a are you a soy how do you eat
cereal soggy or just like crisp I like
it crisp I haven't had cereal in a while
but Nei soy I don't like a soggy soy I'm
super soy super soggy so you like pour
the milk and then you like sit for a
while either grape nuts or Captain
Crunch two very extreme cereals but both
do so well with soggy I like needed it's
almost like not even cereal it's like a
Kasha like I need to be like a that's
how I eat it you drink it like grape
nuts right away it's like eating rocks
they're that hard you got to let that
soak a little bit a little in there a
little honey yeah all right Gary If This
Were a real garage sale what would be
the most valuable thing on the table you
think definitely not I the kofax rookie
or but the garden seats really you know
can have a huge variable those would be
the two that I would negotiate down that
bobblehead doll is that working oh this
one yeah I saw this on eBay the other
day I think it was like 80 cents 80 you
know with free shipping guess what I own
100,000 of these so now now you're
talking got real money n this real real
physical there you
go